clear rivers was born on september 5th
1982. during her delivery her real
mother passed away due to childbirth
complications
so she mostly grew up with her father he
would take her on trips to his
waterfront cabin teaching her to fish
and do other outdoor activities
her father did remarry at some point and
clear came to love her stepmother when
she was six or seven she would worry and
worry about her parents dying
so much so that it would keep her lying
awake at night in 1992 when clear was
just 10 years old her worst fears came
true when her dad stepped into a
7-eleven and an armed robber told him
don't turn around for whatever reason he
did turn around
and that would be the last thing he ever
did to learn what happened to clear in
between final destinations one and two
and the details added to her backstory
in the novelization
stick around to the end of this video
welcome to horror history my name is
cece's world and i haven't gotten a
haircut in about a year and a half
clear rivers was the first returning
character in the final destination
franchise and she's also one of the most
unique exhibiting an ability that no
other character seems to possess
before we get started i accidentally got
a second copy of final destination on
blu-ray so i'm giving it away it's enter
to win you just have to be following me
on instant grandmother and like
this post full rules are in the
description
[Music]
after losing her father clear's life
went to show her stepmother remarried to
some [ __ ] that she never even liked
when clear's real dad was alive and the
new husband who is technically not
clear's stepfather didn't want kids
so her stepmother who technically is
still her stepmother and guardian
began to neglect her naturally this
causes claire to become goth just as any
kid with a troubled home life does in a
movie but clear would take it one step
further in 1998 she turned 16 years old
emancipated and began living alone in
her father's old house she became an
experimental artist and welder
expressing herself through strange
experimental art she also enjoyed
watching crime drama shows
it's not clear no pun intended if she
made any friends in high school but it
would appear that she doesn't have any
friends in her senior year french class
she is however the most prolific french
speaker in her class
the airport does not endorse solicitors
this is the classes big end of year
field trip to paris france the departure
date is may 13th
1999. clear mostly has her nose in a
book the entire time
tropic of cancer by henry miller she
gets coffee in a snack before boarding
and at the gates another book falls out
of her bag and a classmate named alex
browning helps her pick it up when she
takes it it's open to a page about the
princess of wales dying in a car crash
in 1997
her first of many ominous signs she
listens to headphones while boarding and
is mostly disconnected from the rest of
the class as she takes her seat in row
23
cj where she started to feel a strange
paranoia but did not know where the
feeling was coming from
the next thing she knows alex browning
is having a meltdown geeking out and
yelling that the plane is going to
explode in that moment clear felt
the same uneasiness that alex felt and
for whatever reason
she believed him and exited the aircraft
to sit alone in the gate area
this is the first example of her unique
ability to feel what others are feeling
she's not a visionary like alex kimberly
wendy nick
or sam and she's not a psychic she can't
read people's minds but she can read
people's feelings
she seems to be the only one to carry
this ability unlike her ability to see
signs which seems to be possible for
anyone as long as they know to look sure
enough the plane explodes just as alex
predicted and 39 minutes later the seven
survivors which include
six classmates and one teacher are moved
to a closed off room there's a lot of
hostility towards alex so clear lives up
to her namesake and
clears the air why do you think i'm some
sort of he's not a witch
over an hour later at 11 20 p.m clear is
being interviewed by the fbi
explaining that she saw and heard alex
and believed him when the families
arrive
clear is the only one with nobody to
show up for her and she gets a ride home
from alex's parents on june 21
1999 clear attends the memorial for the
flight 180 victims alone
and gives alex a white rose for saving
her life this moment is photographed and
ends up in the newspaper she feels this
unexplainable attraction towards him
and creates a sculpture in her garage of
how he makes her feel
it's you not a likeness
it's how you make me feel alex
on the night of todd wagner's death
clear feels a similar feeling to the one
she felt on the plane and goes to the
wagoner's house which is soon surrounded
by official vehicles after an apparent
self-immolation
she hides out near the house and tries
to warn alex to get out after he shows
up because him being there makes him
look suss in the eyes of the fbi
alex shows up at her house the next day
wondering why she was there and she
explains her sculpture to her
sculpture doesn't even know what or why
it is it's reluctance to take form
and you're creating an absolute but
incomprehensible attraction
she suggests that they go to see todd's
corpse to possibly better understand the
way they're feeling about all of the
recent events i wish just
once that a girl would take me to the
morgue to see my best friend's corpse on
a first date
kiss me she's got the right idea they
sneak in through the roof when they find
todd they're startled by a chemical
induced spasm in his arm
then caught off guard by the coroner
clear notices the marks on todd's neck
suggesting that he had pulled on the
wire and it was not a suicide the
coroner explains that death has a new
design for them but clear isn't
convinced they go the next day to get
coffee
sorry claire the second date was not as
inspired as the first clear thinks that
the death omens theory
isn't real claiming you can find signs
anywhere if you believe in them
she still believes todd killed himself
but that belief would be shaken not long
after when either coincidence or fate
brings together all the remaining flight
180 survivors
[Music]
when each survivor somehow ends up in
the same spot alex tries to warn the
others about his theory
that each of them is still on death's
list things get heated and terry chaney
ends up becoming the victim of a bus
clear is shaken by the incident because
it basically proves alex's theory to be
true
she becomes semi-obsessed with talking
to him to the point that alex's dad
recognizes her voice when she asks for
him and alex is burned out from dealing
with her so he starts ignoring her i
think part of the reason for clear's
attraction to him is her ability to
sense feeling when alex has a vision
it's accompanied by a lot of intense
feelings due to how real his visions can
seem
since clear can detect these feelings
alex is like a sensory overload for her
it's like how dogs have a great sense of
smell so they love things that smell
don't they yes they do after death comes
for their teacher miss luton the fbi
wants to arrest alex thinking he's
responsible so they ask clear if she
knows where he is they ask her to let
them know if she hears from him and she
notices that they're keeping an eye on
her to see if she'll reveal his location
so instead of contacting alex she
arranges a meeting with the other
remaining survivors carter and billy she
has harder drive her to where she thinks
alex
is it's left up to the audience to
speculate exactly how she knew his
location if he wasn't talking to her at
the time and i theorized that she was
able to detect his intense feelings like
she could essentially use her own sense
of feeling as a sort of dowsing device
when she's sure that they're not being
watched she gets out and goes across the
tree line to the beach where she finds
him he ponders about a world where the
flight 180 victims are safe and she
tells him about her father's death
wishing there was a world where he was
safe they get into carter's car with
clear planning to take alex to her
father's cabin to hide out but carter
loses it after finding out that his
death is essentially
inevitable this causes him to become
semi-suicidal thinking that he'd rather
go out on his own free will
clear tells him she wants him to stop
the car so he sarcastically obeys and
parks on a railroad crossing with an
oncoming train and refuses to get out
the rest of them have to flee the car
and beg carter not to end his own life
and when they're able to convince him
the car stalls and carter finds himself
locked in the vehicle
alex is narrowly able to pull him to
safety and after doing so clear realizes
how close she was to losing him and
collapses into his arms as the train
goes by it propels a piece of scrap
metal that takes out billy and in the
hysteria
clear is the only one to find a little
moment of sanity and warns alex that the
police are going to show up
and tells him to hide out at her dad's
cabin asap they disaster-proofed the
cabin and clear returns to her own home
for safety
not realizing that alex made a mistake
with his prediction
and that she was actually next on
death's list her experience watching
crime dramas may be the reason that she
realizes that the fbi is watching her
she comes out to straight up tell them
that she won't turn alex in they offer
to bring him into protective custody
where he'll be safe and it's assumed
that she does give away his location in
exchange for his safety but again he
wasn't the one who needed
immediate protection a storm of bruise
and the lightning sets a series of
events in motion
resulting in a loose power line emitting
sparks which threatens her dog rex's
safety and
knocks out the power she runs out to
save him but when she does so lightning
strikes her drying rack and it spins out
of control and punctures the pool which
floods the entire yard
she climbs into her window but the storm
overloads all the electronics in the
house
making it actually more dangerous than
she thought because of the fire hazard
so she flees to her car
unable to get the garage door opener to
work she bashes through to try to escape
accidentally knocking over a can of
flammable turpentine oil which gets
ignited by the loose wire this is when
alex arrives and tries to save her but
inadvertently knocks open a gas cylinder
which rockets its way under the car
realizing the car is going to explode he
decides to sacrifice
himself so that death can theoretically
skip clear but not wanting to lose yet
another person that she cares for she
begs him not to do it
alex grabs the power line and gives her
time to get out of the car before the
explosion the jolt of electricity sends
him flying into the garage and clear
goes to him immediately
and the fbi shows up shortly after an
ambulance is already on the way
so they're able to save alex in the
months that follow alex and clear get
into a relationship
and become friends with the other
survivor carter once they're convinced
that it's over
they all plan a trip to france together
as a symbolic moving on from the horror
that was flight 180.
in december 1999 the three of them
arrive in paris
one night they go out to get drinks at a
cafe between plaza de vege and
sagerman de depressed clear has her
first legal drink a glass of red wine
having just turned 18 a few months ago
and being in france where the required
age is three years younger than in her
home country carter tells them
sometimes it just feels like the two of
you are the only ones you can really
understand
which references the idea that they each
had a unique ability and a unique
connection
clear tells him that she feels that they
won a chance at a full life
and they argue about what death's plan
for them really was all along but alex
sees the signs of another possible
disaster
and for whatever reason his girlfriend
isn't as quick to pick up on his
feelings as she has been during past
incidents
he heads back to the hotel and clear is
concerned and wants to go with him but
he warns her to stay away
just then she sees a sign of her own the
same one alex saw
shortly before terry's accident she
realizes that a bus is going to hit alex
and is able to narrowly warn him before
it happens
but the bus crashes and sets in motion a
chain of events where a dislodge sign
swings in to take his life carter dives
and saves him but in doing so alex is
skipped and the order
resets now putting carter on death's
target and he becomes the victim of
newton's first
law so who's next
based on what she eventually tells the
coroner william bloodworth alex and
clear both escaped death's design dozens
of times
sending the target back and forth
between the two of them over and over in
the year 2000 and most likely becoming
the most skilled escape artist from
death's plans in all of final
destination lore
unfortunately for clear who probably
would have rather gone first as opposed
to losing yet another loved one
she was the more skilled of the two alex
was struck by a falling brick in an
alley causing clear to scream
so loud that nearby merchants called the
police alex was
later pronounced dead and clear was
[Music]
arrested
[Music]
clear was then taken into custody likely
on suspicion that she was the murderer
given that she wasn't friends with any
of the flight 180 victims before the
accident but
was present at the scene of each
subsequent death with the exception of
the teacher miss luton who passed away
in a more private setting
clear was investigated as a possible
cult killer who wanted to take out those
who survived the accident with her based
on some kind of belief or ideology
obviously they had no evidence against
her that wasn't circumstantial
but rather than taking back her freedom
she admits herself to stony brook
institution
in a padded room in the insanity war
although she is put under the care of a
doctor ron fairbairn
she's not mentally ill like the other
patients but rather stays there
voluntarily she's able to monitor what's
going on outside her door using a
security camera but given the fact that
we've literally seen two cases of
exploding monitors you'd think she might
forego that luxury during her time in
confinement she keeps an evidence board
filled with newspaper clippings about
those involved in flight 180 and other
people who had near-death experiences
this must have been difficult to keep
together without using any push pins
on may 13 2000 one year after the crash
of
leaf flight 180 clear hears about an
accident similar in nature to the
explosion in the nearby town of white
plains new york and agrees to meet the
alleged clairvoyant kimberly cormier
requesting that she does not bring any
sharp objects necklaces belts shoelaces
flammable objects or edible objects in
order to ensure her complete safety she
explains to kimberly that the would-be
victims will die in the same order that
they were meant to in the pile up
and warns her not to ignore ominous
looking signs kimberly calls her a
selfish coward before leaving and clear
doesn't seem to mind at the time but she
would later reflect on the exchange and
change her reclusive ways after
rereading the article about the first
route 23 survivor that ran out of extra
time
she checks herself out of stony brook
institution and tracks down kimberly
somehow i'm guessing that she's able to
find kimberly for the same reason she
was able to find alex at the beach
kimberly like alex is a visionary so she
often experiences intense and realistic
feelings that come with those
premonitions kimberly seems to have
even more detailed visions than alex did
so it may have been relatively easy for
clear to track someone like that down
she takes kimberly and officer thomas
burks to the mount abraham coroner
william bloodworth the same man who gave
them the idea about death's list the
previous year
he's expecting them when they arrive and
when pressed by kimberly he reveals that
only the introduction of new life can
defeat
death would have been nice to know a
year ago but whatever
while filling up at the gas station
after this visit we really see how
clear's time alone after alex's death
forced her to become even more cautious
when she alertly spots a teenager
lighting up a cigarette and scolds him
for it probably saving them all from
getting zoolandered into the afterlife
kimberly has another vision but clear is
distracted by a number of possible
disaster triggering moments
she's become so paranoid about the
domino events that could lead to their
deaths that she essentially becomes the
ultimate defense for death's plan
she's always thinking two or three steps
of what's going on in the present
kimberly describes her vision so clear
ends up learning that there was a
pregnant woman
who survived the route 23 pileup thanks
to kimberly's intervention
clear theorizes that according to what
mr bloodworth told them
if this baby is born it'll screw up
that's list and force everyone to get a
new
expiration date with the help of burke
the police officer who was there on the
day of the crash they're able to find
the name and vehicle information of the
pregnant woman
isabella hudson
burke organizes a meeting with the
remaining route 23 survivors and clear
tries to warn them all to look out for
signs
one of the guys eugene thinks they're
all full of bs and gets his coat to
leave
starting an accidental rube goldberg
machine that nearly knocks clear out the
window but for some reason that's still
not enough to convince him that clear
and kimberly are telling the truth and
then things start getting weird like i
honestly don't think i've ever done an
episode of horror history where the
events that i discussed get
this cringe so one of the guys sees what
he perceives
to be a man with hooks sorry i can't
take this seriously so
clear runs downstairs to tell eugene and
another survivor nora but it's no good
and nora gets decapitated by the
elevator
clear comes back upstairs to catch the
tail end of an incident where eugene
stole burke's gun and tried to blow his
brains out but got six duds in a row
which cleared chalks up to
simply not being his turn to die do not
try this at home
if you're subscribed to me they all go
to find the pregnant woman isabella and
each of the route 23 escapees share a
story about how they had cheated death
once before
one woman cat tells a story that is of
particular interest to clear
last may i'm supposed to go instead this
cheesy little bed and breakfast in
pennsylvania right
so anyhow there's this major gas link
that no one knows about and all the
guests
suffocated during the night so what
happened i i don't know i never made it
the the bus i was on splattered some
girl all over the road
she's of course talking about the bus
that hit terry which clear was there to
witness
it turns out that all of the route 23
survivors escaped their first near-death
experience because death had to change
his plans in order to first take out the
flight 180 survivors in other words the
pileup on route 23 was actually just
death trying to clean up those lives
that were extended indirectly
after alex browning saved seven people
from flight 180 with his vision
so clear's fate is very much linked to
everyone in that car
just after clear figures this out their
tire blows out veering them off the road
and badly injuring eugene when the
ambulance shows up she's bossing the
paramedics around
selling themself be careful of these
ridiculous scenarios that she's
anticipated she tries to go along in the
ambulance but they don't let her
so burke makes some calls to find out
that isabella is at a nearby hospital
prepping for delivery
a couple more less important characters
die
but more importantly some farmer gives
clear and kimberly his truck to go to
the hospital end
we have to get to the hospital now but
take my truck the keys are in it
he's a semp we were all thinking it when
they get to the hospital
clear goes to find eugene to try to keep
him safe while kimberly and burke go to
look for isabella
to make sure that the birth goes
smoothly clear is unable to find eugene
because remember he's not a visionary
she can't detect him
she ends up running back into her
comrades after isabella safely delivered
the baby and they celebrate death's
curse
allegedly being over only kimberly has
another vision of the route 23 pileup
and realizes that they were wrong
isabella was never supposed to die kind
of a big oopsie
kimberly envisions someone with bloody
hands driving into a lake which clear
interprets to be eugene and takes off
after him instead of
you know just asking if they were the
hands of someone with dark skin
she finds eugene's room and opens the
door not realizing his oxygen supply
was leaking which really wouldn't be
much of an issue but this
oxygen is flammable it's flammable
oxygen so that means when you unplug the
outlet
which happens it apparently explodes
like the whole room explodes i don't
know
death was getting desperate like an
umpire in an extra innings game
so clear rivers turns into clear well
done meatloaf
in jurassic park life finds a way but in
final destination
death finds a way so on may 15 2000 he
would finish what he started
one year and two days before by cooking
the last survivor that made it off
of volley flight 180. clear rivers was
no more there's an interesting symmetry
to her story with her real mother dying
in childbirth and clear
also passing away after a baby delivery
but it's possible that clear was ready
to go
she had experienced 11 people die first
hand and
considering that she can experience the
feelings of others that's an
unimaginable amount of pain to go
through and at that point in her life
there was really nobody else left for
her to go to
click the video on the left for even
more analysis on the final destination
series and if you love horror remember
to subscribe to cz's world for new
horrors every week ring the death bell
and turn on all notifications i will see
you in the next one assuming we both
survive
if you want to beat death use a face
mask and social distancing